so let's talk a little bit about smart
goals when it comes to your finances and
when I say smart goals I'm not just
saying well thought out or intelligent
goals although I guess it could be that
I'm talking about the acronym
s-m-a-r-t smart goals now the S stands
for specific the m stands for measurable
a stands for achievable R stands for
realistic and T stands for time based I
think achievable and realistic are kind
of common but then it wouldn't be a fun
acronym it would be like smart goals or
smart goals so it's smart goals which is
a little bit easier to remember so what
do we mean by smart goals so for me it's
easy to think about what it is by
thinking about what it isn't so let's
think about what a non-smart goal would
be when it comes to your finances let's
say you just said I want to be rich
that is not a smart goal that is not
specific it is not measurable it might
be achievable depending on how you think
about what rich is but once again we
don't even know because you haven't
Quantified what that is I have what what
does rich mean uh it may be realistic
but we don't know and the time you
haven't given any time there so let's
see if we can turn that into something
more of a smart goal
so let's first Define what it means to
be rich and let's say you want by the
time you are uh 30 years old so I'm
putting some time in there you want to
have enough money for a down payment on
a pretty nice house let's say you want
to have a hundred thousand dollar down
payment so let's see if that if that
meets our smart goal so is it specific I
want to save a hundred thousand dollars
for a down payment on the house on a
house by the time I am 30 years old
that seems specific it's a hundred
thousand dollars for a down payment on a
house is it measurable yes you can see
how much money you have saved for that
down payment how close you are once
you've if you the first year you save
ten thousand dollars you're like wow I'm
ten percent of the weight of my goal the
second year I've ever I've I've saved
twenty thousand dollars Etc you can
measure how you're getting there is
achievable realistic well depending on
your financial circumstances that uh
that seems doable for a lot of folks to
if they're able to save well that they
might be able to save that amount but
once again it depends on your income
your lifestyle your expenses you have to
make sure that's realistic for some
folks that might not be achievable or
realistic for other folks it might be
very achievable and realistic and then
is it time-based well yes uh I just said
by the time I am 30 years old and you
could break that down let's say you're
25 years old right now and you say well
then I'm gonna have to save twenty
thousand dollars a year for the next
five years so you could break that
bigger smart goal into smaller smart
goals okay this coming year I need to
save twenty thousand dollars towards my
down payment on a house once again it's
specific it's measurable depending on
your scenario it may or may not be
achievable if if that twenty thousand
dollars a year is just way too much if
you're making let's say uh forty
thousand dollars a year you might say
okay that's still not a smart goal it's
not necessarily achievable or realistic
maybe you have to moderate that a little
bit bring it down to five or ten
thousand dollars in which case maybe
your larger goal you're going to save
fifty thousand dollars by the time
you're 30. or you'll say I have to raise
a hundred thousand by the time I'm 35.
what smart goals allow you to do is just
um one realize whether you are achieving
them and also have goals that are
achievable in a very clear time frame so
smart goals are useful in practically
anything you do but especially when it
comes to your finances because it's very
easy to say oh well I just want to do
that I want to be comfortable I want to
have enough money I want to be rich
whatever you say but when you just say
it in these kind of loosey-goosey terms
um it's very hard to know whether you're
making progress against those things and
because it's hard to know whether you're
making progress you oftentimes aren't
holding yourself accountable and so
smart goals are going to they're they're
a smart thing to do